(upbeat music)
- [Announcer] Cakes, cookies and brownies.
No, we're not gonna show
you how to make them
because they can be made with
ease thanks to Betty Crocker
who was born in 1921 in Minnesota.
(bell rings)
Well, kind of.
(moves into quick music)
- [Announcer] In 1921, the
Washburn-Crosby Company,
now known as General Mills,
ran a contest for people
to complete a puzzle for
the most coveted prize—
a pin cushion.
Yes, one of your very own.
(cheering)
Surprisingly, a lot of people
- Ouch.
wrote in to claim
(paper crumpling)
their prize but with a little P.S..
- How do I make my sponges?
- How much flour should I use?
- [Announcer] They wanted baking advice.
So the customer service
department began to reply
and to make their tips seem more genuine
they signed their letters, Betty Crocker.
Betty, because it was a cheery all around
American sounding name, and
Crocker after a board member.
Not being a real person
didn't stop Betty Crocker
from having a very successful radio show,
the Betty Crocker Cooking
School of the Air.
With a different accent in every state.
- Welcome to the Betty Crocker,
welcome to the Betty Crocker
Cooking School of the Air.
- [Announcer] But the
lies don't stop there,
let's talk about that
added ingredient, the egg.
You don't need to add a fresh
egg to powdered cake mix
but science says it makes us feel
like we aren't cheating
(finger snaps)
and we're better providers.
(clapping and cheering)
So thanks, Betty Crocker,
for making us all feel like
we know how to bake.
(bubbles popping)
(tone rings)